in the way but we'll see how to do this shortly to better understand how x and z
errors work and the effects that they have within Quantum circuits it's helpful to observe a few simple relationships between these errors and c
not Gates and this will also be helpful in a later lesson first let's start with X errors
or X Gates and how they relate to C not Gates if we apply an X gate to the
Target Cubit of a cot and then apply the C notot then that's equivalent to swapping the order and doing the cot
first on the other hand if we apply an xgate to the control Cubit of a cot and then apply the cot we can't simply
switch the order but instead we have to apply the xate to both cubits and you can check all of these relationships on
your own if you wish by thinking about what happens to standard basis States for instance the situation is similar for Z
errors except that the roles of the control and Target cubits switches in particular if we perform a
zgate on the control Cubit of a c knot and then perform the C knot then that has the same effect as performing the
zgate after the C notot but if we perform the zgate on the target Cubit instead then that's
equivalent to first performing the cot and then applying a zgate to both cubits and finally all of these
relationships are symmetric in the sense that we can always swap The Ordering of the gates on both sides of each equation
which is equivalent to taking the inverse or the conjugate transpose of both sides given that x z and c not
gates are all their own inverses now let's consider phase flip errors and how we can detect and correct
them using the 9 Cubit Shore code here's our encoding circuit and we'll continue to think about the nine
cubits used in the encoding as being grouped into three blocks of three cubits suppose that a z error occurs on
any one of the cubits such as the one indicated here using what we just observed about Z
Gates and cot Gates that's equivalent to two Z errors prior to the cot one on the
control and one on the target Cubit and these errors happen to commute with the other cot in the block so we
can swap the ordering and here's what we obtain the lower Z error doesn't do anything because it's acting on a zero
State and we can slide everything else over and obtain this diagram so what we found is that a z a ER somewhere within
the middle block is equivalent to a z error occurring on the middle Cubit prior to the second encoding phase and
you can reason exactly the same thing for a z error on any of the cubits a phase flip on any Cubit within a block
is equivalent to a phase flip on the corresponding Cubit prior to the inner encoding and that's actually pretty straightforward and intuitive if you
think about how zrs affect the three-bit repetition code so one option for dealing with a z
error is to decode the inner code and then detect and correct Z errors using the outer code which is the modified
version of the 3-bit repetition code that can correct for a z error so that corrects our Z error and
we could re-encode with the inner code if we wanted to do that we can also correct Z errors in
place so to speak without decoding and then re-encoding and it's pretty straightforward but to explain how we
can do that we'll need a little bit more space suppose that we decode the inner code
and then we compute the syndrome for the outer code using the same method as before where we're only involving the three cubits from the outer code and
then we re-encode well we can simplify all of these cots just a little bit and in fact
we can use the relationships between not Gates and cot Gates that we just observed a few moments ago to help with that
task and by doing this we can save four cots and this is the circuit that we obtain if a z error has occurred on one
of the cubits what the syndrome tells us now is not which Cubit experienced a z error but rather which block the Z error
happened in but that's okay because we know that it doesn't matter which Cubit within a block experiences a z error the
effect is the same for all three cubits within that block and so we can in fact correct the Z error by applying a zgate to any of
the cubits within that block this by the way is an example of what's called degeneracy in an error
correcting code where we don't uniquely identify a given error but we're able to correct it anyway finally let's suppose that both a
bit flip and a face flip error occur possibly on the same Cubit for example let's suppose that a
bit flip and a face flip error happens on this cubbit right here as it turns out these errors can be
detected and corrected completely independently and in fact it doesn't matter if we correct each block for a
bit flip first and then correct for phas flips or if we do it the other way around to see this let's first observe
that the ordering of these errors doesn't matter so we can flip them around if we wish the reason for that is not because
x and z commute because they don't x * Z is equal to negative Z * X but the
negative 1 Factor has no effect in this situation because it's a global phase we can now move the Z error just like
before and at this point it's evident that if we were first to correct each block for X errors and then we corrected
for Z errors we would then have corrected both errors alternatively if for some reason
we decided to correct for Z erors first we could do that and the XR has absolutely no effect in that process
that has to be true because number one the X error commutes with every single gate in the circuit that computes the
syndrome for the outer code and number two the ordering between the X eror and the zgate that we apply to make the
correction doesn't matter just like we argued when the zgate was an error so that allows for the correction of the Z
error and we can then correct each block to eliminate the X error so what we've argued is that we
can correct an X error a z error or both on any one of the cubits using this code
in fact we can correct for more errors than that such as multiple X errors as long as they fall into different blocks
or multiple Z errors as long as at most one block gets an odd number of them but going forward what will be most relevant
is that we can correct an X error a z error or both on any one cubit and in the last part of the lesson
we'll see how this is in fact enough to conclude that this code can correct for an arbitrary error on any one
cubit before we move on to the last part of the lesson in which we'll consider arbitrary Quantum errors we'll briefly
consider the performance of the N Cubit short code when errors represented by poly metrices occur randomly on the